[Music]
how many of you moms and dads out there
have spent late evenings with your kids
at the table going over fractions or
whatever it is
having to look online first to remind
yourself how to do it all i know i have
well seems the burden of teaching math
has fallen more upon us at home since
it's
quite difficult to master it all with
the virtual learning but
there's a lot of help out there folks
beastacademy.com is one site
artofproblemsolving.com and
aopsacademy.org
you can go there for various resources
for elementary middle and high
school-aged kids
they even offer live instruction if
you're so inclined
for the student who doesn't want to be
told what to do they want to get in
there and mess around and a lot of kids
are like that
they'd much rather get in there and try
the thing rather than have
certainly than have mom or dad tell them
what to do because that usually doesn't
work very well
as you may know for sometimes with
parents it's
finding someone else to work with them
that might be finding a group of parents
to collaborate with
you know you form your own little mini
pot or whatever maybe or find an online
school like one of ours
richard rusik is the founder and ceo of
art of problem
solving he says when tackling math ask
your child questions in order to teach
them to problem solve
takes more time but you got to have
patience have them look at examples
try different types of media too if
their readers offer them books if they
like videos find the videos online
and try different types of teachers
because with the different videos one
might resonate better than the other